Jeb Bush is finally announced as running
for president and he unveiled his new
logo on Twitter got a lot of people
there it is if someone's nodding off at
the wheel you can just hold that logo up
well is looking at to me it looks like
look at it it's that it looks like the
title graphics from a 90s sitcom that's
that's what it looks like and I thought
that was a strange choice until I saw
the campaign's first commercial and now
it makes sense
take a look paid for by the committee to
elect Jeb Bush president born John
Belushi goes by JEP presidential hopeful
for the GOP just don't ask about his
family
legend once but hey that's his
stand-your-ground legislation led to
Superman's liberation
hey that's dad hey that's Jeb coming
into February - I
[Music]
his brother George's chugga-chugga I
love him his chugga yeah hey thanks for
watching be sure to click subscribe to
see even more great Conan clips you may
now return to your pirated movies and
creepy Japanese pornography